for other people there might their
environment might be a bunch of breaks
got to make sure the kid is doing this
I've got to make sure um this kid is fed
I got to make sure I'm healthy I got to
go for my walk I got to make sure the
dish is set up because I want to be a
good wife and I have this picture of
what wife looks like and my husband and
I have never talked about it and then
you come home and you start pawing at
her or doing you bring home a
flower you might think you are being
romantic here's your gesture and that
might have nothing to do with her breaks
and GS hospitals I've seen couples
dramatically turn their sex lives around
by Simply Having the conversation